hey everybody welcome back to Jaeger
horn today's episode is a little bit of
a special occasion since I'm gonna be
working on a string of buildings it's
really gonna be a bunch of assad's as
opposed to what I've been doing so far
which is just separate standalone
buildings so it's a little bit of a test
to see to one extent I can actually
bring this whole themed area together so
it's kind of experimental in that sense
so without further ado let's get into
the time-lapse all right now the first
building that I wanted to start off with
here is the largest building of the
whole set what you don't actually end up
seeing me do here but what was actually
quite a big part of the creation of this
row of buildings is creating a bit of a
composition over the whole set before I
detail at all so before I move in and
create a facade I like to just put a
bunch of very simple walls and blocks
together in a sort of basic shape but
lacking all of the detail and texture
then I'll get into later just to get an
idea of what kind of composition I want
to have with the facade and in this case
I decided to go for a tallest building
with a spire rights at the right at this
intersection of the paths which is the
building that I'm building right here
and the idea is that all of the other
buildings that are gonna be next to this
are gonna be both lower and sets to the
back a little bit so this building both
comes out to the front the most but it's
also the tallest out of the whole bunch
and I basically kind of did that to get
an idea of like how I want all the
masses to kind of be distributed
alongside this row of facades and I
really feel like having the tallest
building right here is the the most
good-looking way to create this whole
thing I ended up removing most of that
because I don't think it looks really
good on time-lapse to have that whole
mess of random objects right in the
middle of the park but I did take a
picture and like I'm using that picture
as a reference while I am building all
of these buildings and effects honestly
that's the way that I mostly do these
things usually so if you're struggling
with like getting the right composition
of buildings I think this is definitely
something that can help
detailing is something that you just
have to put time into and eventually by
adding enough stuff it'll usually end up
looking good but I always find that I
struggle a lot with composition of
buildings and trying to get the right
shapes and sizes in so that's something
that I actually practice going to long
before the time lapse so honestly most
of the shapes of the buildings have
already been set while I'm working on
this I'm just kind of going through all
the scenery items and adding the kind of
details that I thought would be fitting
for the theme speaking of which the
theme is obviously going to be European
Alpine style much like the rest of the
park and it is mostly inspired again by
Swiss architecture but I think there's
probably quite a bit of Austrian in
there as well it's just kind of general
Alps ish mountain architecture that is
all clustered together so for this first
building I'm going for the really
typical culmination of a stucco ground
floor with some extra scenery details
that you might not always see in real
life like these corner stones and really
fancy entrance and then the second floor
and third floor is all wooden and you've
got those very typical traditional super
large overhanging Gables and eaves on
the roof which I'm quite a big fan of I
actually ended up using this building
later on on Twitter as an example of how
much a single small spire can influence
the way that a building looks because I
was always planning to build a spire on
top of the roof hence why there's a tiny
little wooden post at the outer end of
the roof and I definitely think it makes
a great impact on the way that the
building looks the next thing now I
wanted to do though is work on this
smaller building on the side which is
not as important it doesn't really draw
the attention as much but it does fill
up the whole facade quite nicely and it
is also functional because I at least
wanted some of the buildings to be
functional and there's gonna be some
toilets in this building right here
presumably these toilets are probably
gonna be quite a bit larger in real life
than that single tile that the in-game
toilets are so realistically there
should probably be a whole toilet
building throughout this facade soon
toilets should be quite large but for
now functionally at least it is just one
tile right here now one of my biggest
challenges with making this whole facade
kind of well convincingly Alpine themed
is that a lot of the building styles
that I'm using like this one as well
again the ground floor is just rock and
stucco and the upper floors are wooden
and we have these typical balconies
coming out at the front and these large
eaves and Gables the problem with this
kind of building is that they usually
set apart from each other and they're
never really connected there's always at
least a little bit of space between
these and when you look at these typical
traditional European mountain villages
it's really just a bunch of these
buildings that are spread out apart from
each other
with all these gardens and roads in
between so trying to put these buildings
together and make them separate facades
of what is actually really just one
single building is something that at
least I found quite difficult to do
since these buildings look most
convincing when they're actually spread
apart when they're not connected in this
way but I had to connect them in some
way and especially the fact that they
all have these roofs which overhang on
the sides in the front of the building
makes it quite hard to actually connect
these buildings and not have stuff kind
of clip into each other or make stuff
look really awkward so with this
building I guess I kind of tried to get
over that issue by making the building
angle slightly different so it kind of
curves away from the other building
which means that the roof eaves don't
end up clipping into each other and that
looks a little bit nicer but for this
next building I decided to make the roof
not well parallel actually to the path
whereas with the other buildings you can
see the gable turning toward the path
but in this this case it's gonna be
parallel and I took a lot of inspiration
here and I definitely mean a lot of
inspiration to the point of rip offing
especially in this building in just the
textures and detailing is different from
the composition of the buildings in
europa parks
area which is a beautiful area in the
Swiss part where the bobsled kinda like
twists around the buildings in the area
and there's a tiny little alpine village
right in the middle of that whole
bobsled track and it's really cute and
charming I don't know if too many people
go there because it's a little bit of a
hidden thing and there's a just a very
narrow path leading through it but I
thought the idea of having a sort of
horizontal part that connects to another
building with the gable looking to the
front and outward was something that
worked out quite well and they also
created this little space underneath the
building where you could sit or there
would be some scenery down there so I
thought that was a really neat idea and
decided to put that in here and I think
for the overall composition it works
quite nicely because as you can see
everything is kind of curving away from
that front building everything is also
kind of getting a little bit lower when
you're looking at the front building and
that just kind of creates the whole
impression that that building in the
front is a little bit taller than it
really is so yeah I think that works out
quite nicely and now what i'm doing here
is finally working on this spire and
you'll see in a minute the huge impact
that adding one simple small spire to
the front of a building makes when it
comes to the building I remember one of
the tweets at the time and embarassingly
I'm talking about months ago here one of
the tweets said that this one spire kind
of turned the building from a Colorado
to a Switzerland kind of place which
definitely makes sense you know up until
this spire I think the buildings are
somewhat generally alpine but especially
with the addition of this spire I think
it gets a way more Swiss kind of look to
it I before I started working on this I
wanted to get some references so what I
usually do is I create a folder
somewhere on my computer's image folder
and basically made it the Swiss are
Nouveau and
Belle Epoque kind of Alpine architecture
folder and just put every single Swiss
building that I found that fits into the
style in there and looked at a bunch of
the spires and figured hey I can
actually kind of make something like
that so this little spire is a bit of
the results bit of an amalgamation of
all the ones that I found there but I
think it definitely helps sell the theme
a little bit more and it creates a bit
more of a weenie it's not exactly a
weenie but it definitely makes the
building stand out much more from the
other buildings I think when you're
building a a single building with
multiple facades so you've got a single
building like this but you're trying to
make it look like it's multiple
buildings just to make it much more
charming I think it always works to
create some buildings where they're just
kind of filler you don't really have to
look at them they're just kind of there
to settle the theme and you have a few
select buildings which are the main
points of attention so you've got a few
buildings which is slightly more
detailed slightly taller and which
guests are gonna want to be drawn toward
so for me I decided that would be this
building right on the corner which is
fuller and more detailed and has that
spire unlike the rest of the buildings
which from a park standpoint I think
works out quite nicely as well because
it's the only building that's in full
frontal view when you're coming toward
this area from the path that's right in
front of it so I think that is drawing
you into the facade a lot more than if
this were for instance just a bunch of
houses that all have the same height and
all have a very similar design I know
there's that whole school of life video
about how to design a great city there's
a bunch of stuff that I disagree and
agree with on that video but one of the
things is they do advocate to make every
building a similar height and the
similar style and similar design and
while I do agree with that you
definitely need some points of interest
and some things that kind of break them
all so in this case that's the front
building now all of these other
buildings are again just kind of filler
trying to fit into the rest of the
style although I am definitely bringing
some slight variations with every
building that I add so this building for
instance has slightly different colors
for instance the the second floor has
that yellow stucco going on and then the
bottom floor has that interesting sort
of I told it the porch there we go has
that interesting porch going on and a
whole different color scheme and there's
also a bit of timber framing on the top
here actually I guess I decided to redo
the color of that hmm but yeah as you
can see in any case every building has
some slightly different detailing some
slightly different shapes
I definitely don't repeat the themes
from any building that I've built so far
besides I think it's more fun to do it
this way with every building to make
something that fits in with the rest
that you've got so far but also
experiment with some other stuff I think
that's just more fun than trying to
recreate the same style over and over
again with every part of the building
that you creates also it is time for
some flowers and I wish there were some
like flower boxes that were a little bit
more like the ones that you see in a lot
of these Alpine villages what I've
always noticed is that if you go to
these places there are flower boxes but
unlike the ones in planet coaster where
the flowers just kind of neatly stay
inside the boxes these things just go
everywhere and they're absolutely huge
and most of the time you can't even see
the boxes that the flowers are in
anymore it's just these huge bunches of
flowers all over the balconies and the
windows of these buildings which is
awesome because foliage always makes a
building look way more inviting and
charming but it's kind of difficult to
do in planet coaster because none of the
flower boxes actually do that so that's
why I decided to add some of my own
flowers into the flower boxes there I
think that's something that I've been
doing for quite a while but I barely
talked about why I do that but that's
basically why I think it works a lot
better to just add a heap of flowers
into the flower boxes rather than just
leaving them the way that they are now
over here I could not be damned to
create this whole roof over again
because
God knows it is really annoying to do
and it takes away too many pieces so I
decided to bring it over from another
building honestly what I think one of
the greatest blessings is a planet
coaster it's the fact that you can take
things in and out of a certain building
so even though this was a separate
building from the station building that
I drew the roof from you can basically
select some scenery pieces from a
building say for instance the station
that I just did and remove them from the
building then click on another building
and multi-select the scenery pieces and
click the icon which makes you add
separate scenery pieces to a building
and that way you can just kind of switch
which building the scenery pieces belong
to and I think at times that's a really
awesome trick to just kind of copy over
some of the things which you made
previously which you want to reuse in
another build so yeah I ended up doing
that here because that definitely ends
up saving a lot of time and there are
also some typical little touches that I
added in here like the little spire
that's on top of the roof right there
anytime that there is a bunch of roofs
coming together or there's a little
pointy bit I always just like getting
one of those Christmas decorations those
icings
to create a little spire shape and then
use the cables which is to spot the only
really narrow tall vertical piece that
we have to create a small spire which is
heavily influenced by the efteling but
which you can see in a lot of styles
around the world and what also kind of
inspired me on this building is in a lot
of villages in the alpine area the only
ones that I have real experience with
are the ones in Austria but I know this
definitely happens throughout the Alps
there are many buildings where they use
paint to decorate the buildings
supposedly I've been told but I'm not
sure if this is theory but I think it
probably is supposedly decorations were
painted because that's cheaper and the
farmers of the mountains weren't exactly
the most rich people but they still want
their houses to look somewhat
interesting so rather than getting
actual real
Skol decorations and carving them into
walls they just painted them over the
walls which doesn't make a lot of sense
but there's nothing that you can really
do in planet coaster to get that kind of
look but I think the icing pieces from
the Christmas set actually work quite
well so there's a little bit of
decorations right beside the window
right there and finally I do believe
this is the final building of this build
I decided to build one more house with
some slightly different slanted roofs I
think for me slanting your roof slightly
different for every single building is
something that gets kind of annoying
over time but it definitely is really
rewarding since it's one of those very
minut differences which still makes you
like recognize that certain buildings
are different rather than getting the
same pitch in the roof for every damn
building
so yeah I'm mostly using these custom
placeable roofs here just to make sure
that the pitch if the roof is slightly
different for every building and then
there is the D beams that hold up the
roof which you see in a lot of Alpine
architecture throughout Europe which are
just so typical that I want an at least
one building where you've got a lot of
these beams and finally and this is
really become something that I'm almost
over using in the Jaeger horn build I am
placing the small spire if you can call
it that in the front of the building
with the gable decorations by placing
all of these beams in the front and a
vertical wooden post now if I remember
correctly I think there is going to be a
small stall in this building that's why
there should be a tiny door I was
spending way too long trying to get the
right parasols but I just ended up going
with these in the end but yeah there we
go there's a little shop definitely
wanted to make sure that most of the the
shops and stuff like that is going to be
in this one big building here
if I could I probably would have made
this an actual restaurant that would
have been a perfect space for it but
with plenty coastal limitations a small
stall is just about everything that I
can get in there but you know the idea
is still more or less the same this is a
big row of facades which kind of sets
the mood as a village but at the same
time it's a single building with most of
the important facilities in the park
which I didn't have so far because to be
very honest I always forget about
placing toilets and stalls in my parks
so I'm glad at least this time I was on
time to have these kind of things
oh and I guess there's also a little bit
of a mother in touch in the fact that
there's a lot of glass on the upper
floor as well and yeah here we go
bunch of decorations again just to make
everything look a little bit fancy I
suppose maybe it's a little bit too
fancy but you know it's a theme park
besides I do like the way that this
looks I don't think many theme parks
would do this kind of thing think for
theme park realism it's a little bit
over the top but to be perfectly honest
like I said I just like the way that
this looks so there's decorations
everywhere just deal with it I guess
and I think at this point it's more or
less done it's just a little bit of
clutter that I wanted to add here and
there and I do have to say the facade is
not entirely finished yet but finishing
some of the remaining stuff that I still
need to do is gonna be part of the next
episode in which I will have an overview
of what it looks like in the finished
products but for now I'm actually not
going to show you very much of that yet
it's not entirely finished yet and we'll
get to finishing up this whole row of
buildings in the next episode including
the backstage areas so yeah thanks for
watching and I hope to see you guys next
time
[Music]
you